hi Bryan so Instapaper has a very
curious like lineage in history could
you just explain that sure
so Instapaper was started by a single
guy named Marco Arment and he built the
entire products and service and operated
it from 2008 to 2013 Marco beside
Instapaper is was previously known for
being the CTO of tumblr and instantly
Bert was kind of his side project that
he worked on while he was at tumblr so
my impression was he would work nights
and weekends he eventually launched this
thing it had quite a bit of fanfare
early on even though it was just a
bookmarking service at the time yeah so
it was early days App Store so this is
even pre App Store so we're talking
about an ure 2008 Marco launches this
this bookmarking service called
Instapaper
and essentially just a website and a
bookmarklet so you could save articles
using the bookmarklet and all was was a
website coming into like March or April
2008 he launched the reading mode for
instapaper using its text parser so the
text parser would take an article from a
website extract just the text and the
images and provide just the reading view
and experience so if used Instapaper
you're pretty familiar with this it's
one of the core value propositions and
then in August 2008 he launched with
basically the App Store launch he
launched in Sniper for iOS which
leveraged the book marketing service and
the text parser to kind of create
Instapaper experience that kind of were
familiar with today yeah and I think it
was the first time where you had this
combination of bookmarking experience
this text parser that would extract the
important parts of articles and then
also the mobile application where it was
kind of all the articles were saved
offline and kind of available to you
wherever you were I think in the early
days of Instapaper
in that 2008 App Store world instant
papers solved three key pain points
consumer pain points the first one was
if you remember early i phone days there
early mobile networks were really slow
and it was like
possible to load a website so you'd be
waiting forever things becoming pretty
progressively and then when a dude load
it was impossible to read the content
because there's no such thing as the
mobile web
until you to pinch to zoom and try to
zoom in on this column and it and then
you'd be like panning around and it was
like this really weird experience I
think the third thing was that the
iPhone was kind of primed to be a
reading device because it was always
with you but for a lot of reasons it was
not really a good reading device because
there were no good reading applications
the screen wasn't really good and so
instapaper comes along and it lets you
save articles the articles are perfectly
formatted you can sync the articles
while you're on Wi-Fi and then access
them from anywhere and so I think it
solves and then also like back in the
AppStore days in 2008 there were not a
lot of really useful mobile applications
I don't think there were like a lot of
at fart apps yeah things like this
and so I think at the time became was
pretty revolutionary and installed a lot
of pain points yeah and as such kind of
had a pretty huge addressable market
which is almost anyone with an iPhone
right and as the iPhone user base grew
and so people kind of grew alongside it
now
you fast forward to 2018 most of those
things are no longer problems you have
LTE networks that are super fast the
mobile web has its problems and there's
various efforts to try to solve them
like accelerated accelerated mobile
pages from Google but at the end of the
day you can still load a website and
read it pretty easily and then the third
one is there's actually tons of reading
applications now and iPhone is a main
reading device for a lot of people
whether they use Kindle or Apple News or
New York Times or Wall Street Journal or
you use some aggregator like reddit or
hacker news or Twitter it's fairly easy
to read on your phone now and so I think
the market has shifted from something
that had kind of like a pretty wide
appeal in the early days to something
that's far more niche now and basically
the use case for instance
is you are kind of like a voracious
media consumer you you source content
from a lot of different places that
might be directly from publishers it
might be from news ideas like reddit
Accra news you mean it may be from
social like Twitter or Facebook and you
essentially need a place to stage all
that content temporarily until the time
that you have enough time to kind of
read it in bulk right go through it in
bulk and I think the the market size for
that is is fairly modest and I think
that's part of the reason that both
pocket and Instapaper wound up landing
at larger companies back in 2016 and
readability wind up shutting down
because actually I think the market
appeal for that product is fairly
limited and it's not one that's like
massively growing over time but did you
notice when Safari launched the reading
list a decrease in users so when that
happened I believe it was 2011 or 12 I
wasn't involved in speed for no time and
I haven't looked at those historical
trends to see if that was the case but
it's not just so far it's actually a lot
of a lot of applications save for later
became a feature of a lot of things so
like YouTube New York Times Wall Street
Journal Safari all these things have
like this reading list save for later
like I found this thing and I want to
come back to it but I don't have time
right now
yeah and so I think all those things
kind of chip away at kind of like the
usefulness of this core service and
there is a large user base who's still
using it daily weekly monthly and it's
been kind of a big privilege for me to
have the opportunity to service those
those types of people but yeah let's
let's go back to the intermediate time
between the creation and now because I
think that's instapaper stories
particularly interesting so talk about
the time how beta Works acquired it sure
so the story that I've heard and I
joined beta work shortly after the
acquisition and joined the Institute
paper founding team the bad works and
thank you the story is that Marco wakes
up at 2:00 in the morning he's like a
little restless he's trying to figure
out what to do with instapaper I think
there were a couple factors there couple
reasons why I and I haven't talked to
mark about this directly so this is kind
of my hypothesis but I think one was
Marco was probably interested in working
on some other projects like overcast
which is his his current podcasting
service its mobile app and service that
he runs I think also in 2012 and so the
timeframe for this is late 2012 in April
2012 an important thing happens in this
history which is a read it later Inc
which was a read later company
originally for Firefox both for Firefox
built mobile apps and so on they they
wound up launching relaunching and
rebranding his pocket and so this is
April 2012 and in doing so they launched
they won had raised a lot of capital
they had several engineers working on it
and they had launched I've is and
Android applications for free in the App
Store now instapaper had no Android
application and the iPhone app was $3.99
to download and in relaunching pocket in
2012 I think you know I've looked at the
the downloads for Instapaper and they
just start tanking after April 2012 and
so I think you know you have this
dynamic where you have this service
that's really strong but there's a free
competitor that's also really strong and
people will always seek the free
competitor so I think the combination of
fatigue from running the service and
pocket launching as a free application
2012 led marco to rethink what he was
doing with Instapaper
and so the story is he wakes up at 2:00
in the morning he creeps downstairs he's
trying to think about what to do with
Instapaper
he reaches out to john Borthwick who's
the CEO beta works now
John Borthwick and bata works had
invested in tumblr in the very early
days in their seed round John Borthwick
had Marco Arment come to beta works and
talked about mobile app development so
they had a good relationship there
already and Marco basically said to John
you know I've been thinking about what
to do with instapaper
I've been thinking about a long-term
home for it and I think beta works could
be that home and so they eventually
worked out a deal where beta works would
have a majority share of instapaper
and Marco would retain some ownership
and into the paper and continue to act
as an advisor and beta works the
understanding was that beta works would
continue to invest in Instapaper staff a
team around it and continue to build it
so that's that that was announced in
April 2013 and so you figure that
probably took like about four four
months from December 2012 which is my
understanding of the timeline uh-huh and
at which point you get hired by beta
works to run it and then you run
Instapaper within beta works for a
couple years and then how did the
Pinterest thing happen yeah so I think
we should just back up a second and so I
was hired in July 2013 and I was not
hired to run Instapaper I was hired as
an iOS developer for Instapaper and so I
had started a company the company had
never got more than a few thousand
people who signed up for it it was a
location-based social networking company
and so I started in 2011 by 2013 it was
really not working I had gone to beta
works for an investment and they had
said we're not interested investing in
this space but we really like you and we
want to work with you and it doesn't
matter if it's next week a month when I
have six months from now a year from now
just keep us in the loop let us know how
it goes and we'd love to have you here
and so when the company folded I went to
beta doric sounds like look new job and
actually the person was talking to his
Nick Charles oh you know as well and so
I said hey I need a job and the
opportunities were done not done which
got shuttered within a few months of my
joining
this this gift search engine called
giffy which I was like the thing from
the 90s like this is crazy but I do
wonder what that road would looked like
if I had taken that one and then the
third one was Instapaper and in Super
was this pretty prestigious application
that was like a long time in the app
store I had used it in the past I was I
was kind of interested in it so I
interviewed for that job I joined as the
iOS developer and I think a lot of the
the skills I had from starting a company
and that perspective had carried over
there were a lot of gaps in terms of who
was writing blog posts who was doing the
marketing who was building product
strategy and so on and so forth and so I
just slowly started to pick up some of
those things and there's a whole story
about how I became into the leadership
position I don't know if you yea go into
okay yeah well so essentially what
happened is even in my first interviews
I had said to the to the person running
it who's a beta works partner named
Andrew mcLaughlin he I said to him that
I did a competitive analysis of across
instapaper pocket readability and I'd
said to Andrew that I didn't think
Instapaper could compete as a paid
application in the market with strong
free competitors yeah it just didn't
make any sense
yeah at the time did they have a
subscription model after the paid were
they doing like freemium mm-hmm so at
the time pocket was totally free okay
for everything every feature everything
was free okay I think readability was
the same and so you had Instapaper which
had a 399 app download in 2013 and and
going back in time it had actually been
more expensive and then also a $1 per
month subscription for search
functionality so I have this full text
search feature where if you had saved an
article about Obama you could search
Obama and it would surface the article
right even if it was in the title mm-hmm
so even in that early interview I
basically said like Instapaper should be
a free application and as I was hired I
kind of advocated for this direction
there was a lot of pushback from it from
leadership where because the app
downloads were 40 to 50 percent of
revenue from Instapaper there was a lot
of hesitation around just eliminating it
and so what I did is I had been in touch
with representative Apple via one of
their education programs and I told her
that we were interested in having
instapaper participate in free a path
week and so free app of the week is a
program that the app store runs where
they take a paid application they make
it free they put it like right in the
front page of the app store or what used
to be the front page of the app store
and give it like a pretty prominent
treatment a couple weeks later she got
back to me and said there was a slot it
was like sometime in December 2013 and
so basically I had gone to Andrew who
was running Instapaper at the time and I
said listen we have this opportunity to
do free app of the week I want to test
the hypothesis of making its debate for
free and so what I'd like to do is give
a two month free trial to instapaper
subscription for everyone who signs up
during the free app of the week trial
period and I want to measure how many of
them we convert after the two months and
when I want the hypothesis to be is to
see if we can continue to build the
business by transitioning from a paid
application with a subscription to a
freemium application and so we had a
couple chats we eventually went through
with the free app of the week we
executed on this plan in that time in
that one-week period we had more app
downloads than we had an aggregate over
the past two years and we increased
their subscriptions by like 10 to 15
percent and so we basically had it so
that three weeks before it expired there
was a little yeah notification that came
up in the app and then like a couple
days before it expired there was a
couple of notification that went up in
the app saying like your free trial is
going to expire consider consider
subscribing so what did that percentage
breakdown of new users how many
subscribed so so the way this worked was
was interesting I think we had
over a million downloads of the million
downloads
I think only 650,000 people created
accounts meaning that like people
download it and just can you use it
without an account no and so they never
opened it or they open it and we're
likes I forget it so that you do have
the create account I've been to to get
the experience and then of those people
many turned out yeah I think we retained
maybe 15% of them and then of the 15% we
got some of them became subscribers I
don't want to target members because
because you can work out the percentages
but we had a 10 to 15% increase in our
subscription base yes and so basically
what approved is that I think it proved
a couple things one is that the paid app
download was a major cap on our growth
and that we were not able to compete in
the market with strong free competitors
as a paid application and that too when
people use the application we could
convert them in a pretty predictable
reliable way and that they would convert
and see the value once they would
started using it and so what I had
proposed and this is January 2014
basically after we executed this
successfully John and Andrew were like
you can be a general manager so I set
out the plan for 2014 and the plan was
preciate forward it was make the
application free and by the first step
was creating more features for the
subscription package and then increasing
the price of subscription from one
dollar a month to three dollars per
month and then making the application
free and so over the next eight or nine
months we built rebuilds highlighting
and then we capped highlighting so you
can make I think five or ten highlights
per month but after that you need paid
subscription we built text-to-speech
which we offered for free but we had a
playlist feature where you could select
multiple articles new text-to-speech and
that was paid and so we try to strike
this balance between like the free
aspects of the feature and kind of like
the more Pro and like what you would
have to pay for and then we did a couple
of other small things and then in
September 2014
we made the application free and
launched a new subscription pricing so
we did that across iOS Android and web
and and then after that I was promoted
to CEO in the leadership position and
that's kind of that right kind of how I
went from like the iOS guy into into a
leadership position we took a pretty big
hit I think which was expected on the
revenue side for a couple months but
within six to eight months we had
recouped what we had lost and the on the
monthly revenue and we were actually
back into a growth trajectory which
which was awesome to see and then a lot
of my focus moving from that late 2014
to mid 2016 when we sold it to Pinterest
was getting kind of the the business
fundamentals right making sure that we
had control over our costs and as we
continue to grow our revenue hit a place
where we were breakeven and profitable
and that was kind of my main goal moving
through 2016 and then so I think that's
kind of okay cuts up both as much as I
know
so yeah that's right and so do you know
what motivated the acquisition interest
from from Pinterest yeah so we had
fielded some interests even going back
in 2015 from them from from other
companies okay
there were two large media companies in
New York and one one media company on
the west coast one of the large New York
media companies sent us a letter of
intent for a large sum very large so it
was um an eight-figure range yeah as big
and so we were like you know we're at
beta works and we're talking about it
and talking about like the long term
prospects of Instapaper and and whether
or not this made sense and I think
everyone felt like this this was a good
outcome at least for the shareholders
yeah so you think I think sometimes you
think about the people who use the
product you think about the employees
anything about the shareholders I think
unfortunately in technology and
motivations of each of those groups are
usually very different mm-hmm or
sometimes very different and not always
clear and not always clear now and so I
think what's great now with the the new
incarnation of instigator since we've
spun it out to Pinterest is those things
are very in line yeah I think we should
spend time talking about yeah but I
think in this case the motivation was
largely around the shareholders and so
we went ahead with this letter of intent
we did all the diligence with these
people I did like deep tech diligence
with these people there's like there's a
picture on my Instagram from back in
2015 where I'm sleeping at my desk with
my feet on the desks like someone
someone took a picture of me I just and
I remember it was like I just launched a
big app update and done all this tech
diligence and I was like I was exhausted
I was wiped and then I think we had an
eight week quiet period where they were
due diligence and so on and so forth and
in week six they pulled out because of a
strategic change in direction and and it
was it was really rough I mean I
remember it was actually Halloween 2015
actually remember really well because I
member getting pulled into a conference
room being told like they they backed
out and that was that I I went out and
got pretty drunk that weekend and just
like trying to take my mind off of it
I felt okay about it until the Monday I
got back to work and I was like oh man
has to actually like built this company
again like I was like I was in the more
like alright we're like gonna do this
thing and it's tough like you get all
your emotions tied into it you think
it's gonna be a big change it's at least
a new chapter
yeah and back and not to mention like
the significant amount of money that
would have been yeah yeah and so I I
think yeah I think like there were there
were a lot of things where you were on a
certain trajectory there and I was like
I know I was like looking at houses oh
wow you really gonna do work I mean I
was like it was it seemed like a done
deal I was like gonna put a down payment
on the place and like Sawan us or you
know right in South Brooklyn somewhere
and and then it's just like boom now
you're back to coming back to where you
were and I think what's hard to because
I like the whole team knew about it the
whole team there's like three or four of
us all right but still I mean it's kind
of rough to go back to everyone and be
like hey by the way this isn't happening
anymore and so I was pretty deflated I
think like as as you might expect we
went back to the other large media
company the West Coast media company and
started those conversations again and
then Pinterest had been talking about it
works separately about things they're
corporate of have been talking about it
works they mentioned that they were
interested in news we had a meeting with
our Corp dev the I had a meeting with
Andrew and and the guy was trying to opt
out at the time I didn't think the
meeting went particularly well like I
was like you know it's kind of like this
feels like a waste of time I don't know
why we keep why we're doing this like
spending at new conversations whatever
yeah and and then eventually we got
connected with the head of product at
Pinterest a senior PMI Pinterest there
was some connection from with Andrew and
senior PM from the Google days and so
they knew each other and was very
friendly and and then we continued talks
with them so but these initial talks
were in December 2015 and the
acquisition happened like signed and
done in August 2016 so you're talking
about a nine-month process and it wasn't
all on I mean it was like we had talks
and I cooled off and I came back and
then there was like a negotiating period
or whatever just to kind of illustrate I
mean from the time that we fielded
initial acquisition interest until a
time that we sold the company was over a
year's thirteen months and so these
things like take a fairly long time and
you may you know have a party that's
interested and pulls out and and so I
learned a lot from from the whole
process so so like psychologically for
someone in your shoes you know what do
you tell them at this point like you
know
don't look at houses until you have a
check or yeah how do you manage the
psychology of it yeah
so I would say definitely don't don't
count your eggs before they hatch right
I mean that's like that's the expression
I think it's it's tough when you are so
close to something I mean like you know
we were all like when we signed the this
LOI
right we were like high-fiving and stuff
it was like I wasn't impression it was
like a done deal
yeah and to back out of an LOI is from
like a business perspective like usually
they're non-binding but it's it's I
think pretty frowned upon and it can
damage your integrity and your
reputation and so on and so forth and
typically it's not done I learned later
on that you can add breakup fees to
these and so you know I didn't know a
lot about this stuff and this is my
first time going through this process
and so that you can basically say like
if you do pull out you have to pay more
X yeah
and that can kind of just incentivize
them from from doing all this work and
then I think also like yeah when in the
pull out that there's some other issues
like it sends a signal to the market
like maybe something is wrong yeah for
sure when that definitely wasn't the
case but managing psychology I mean
definitely it was definitely a roller
coaster I would say you know you have to
like be very calm collected don't don't
shop for houses until the money's in the
bank
because there's no point and and yeah I
just like try not to try not to get too
down on the down swings right but then
ultimately you landed a Pinterest moved
out to California you got soft that's a
lot yeah how's that going that's good so
yeah beta Works is in New York I'm from
New Jersey I grew up in in the New York
area and so as part of the deal it was
understood that we would all be moving
out to to Pinterest and when I say we
all instapaper it was me doing all the
engineering and like all the leadership
piece there is someone doing customer
support maintaining the parser doing
kind of
a variety of other things marketing and
then there was a designer of the three
of us to moved out to Pinterest designer
decided to to go do something different
and how's it been I mean this is a big
difference between New York or San
Francisco and it's not something I want
to get into necessarily on the podcast
I've gotten really into like hiking and
all the outdoor stuff yeah thank you
you're kind of into that too so I think
I think that's that's been awesome
working at a large Silicon Valley
company has been awesome
I've learned a ton about building
products at scale processes for doing
that even just like some of the
methodologies that are used are vastly
different than what I've been exposed to
at smaller scale startups I think of
kind of my career as like the scale at
which I've shipped software so in the
first company I started out of college
no customers
we just demoed it a little bit yeah the
company I started after that we had
6,000 people signed up for it
Instapaper has millions of registered
users and Pinterest has a quarter
billion monthly active users so that's
kind of how I think about like that the
career trajectory of building software
and when I started at Pinterest a lot of
the initial work was around doing
Instapaper integrations and so we did a
variety which which we can talk about
and then once I completed those
integrations I started doing a lot of
Pinterest specific work first as a
individual contributor he's not for
engineer and now starting this year in
January I have been managing a team of
engineers building a new feature yeah
interest so I'm managing a team of eight
very talented software engineers who are
great and I care about very much and and
yeah so I've learned a ton about
managing a larger company and I'm
curious about how it's gone managing it
within Pinterest we had Cortland Allen
from indie hackers on the podcast a
while ago and now that's within stripe
and that that's been an interesting
process for him and in most part for the
most part it's been good like he's been
able to like get off the gas in terms of
like raising the sponsorship money well
and just focusing on the community in
the forum and the content how has it
been for you and how do you manage that
thought process while you also have a
job working on you product at Pinterest
yeah sure so in late 2016
we were at Pinterest we did the
acquisition in August and around
November December we had a conversation
with Pinterest leadership about some
options and directions for Instapaper in
2017
and I think I presented like four or
five options one was one was putting it
staffing a whole team around it and
treating it as a business unit and
trying to grow it the second one was
staffing some data science around it and
seeing what kind of news based insights
we can get on an aggregate basis and so
I was always pretty adamant about not
sharing personal data in any way shape
or form but aggregate information about
the number of saves on a URL might be
interesting might help to power some
features within Pinterest the third
option was to put in a maintenance mode
and just kind of have me and and brodien
the other person for the Instapaper
maintain it and so that would be kind of
like more on the side and and doing that
and then the fourth option was shutting
it down and so I was something that we
discussed
I thought that it was pretty low
investment to keep it running and that
there would be a lot of upset people if
we shut it down and that it didn't make
a lot of sense when we had people
willing to do it and we could do it in a
sustainable way
mm-hmm so it was an option but a non
option kind of it was like we tried
heavily to steer away from that and so
they asked me for my recommendation and
my recommendation was to put in
maintenance mode at the time and just
treat it as a side thing that I
maintained the reason being is that
treating as a business unit I just felt
that every dollar put into Instapaper
could maybe return 70 cents a dollar
like it would be pretty challenging to
have it kind of be an investment that
had a solid return but I felt pretty
strongly that every dollar into
Pinterest would you have $1 $10 $25 30
and so it didn't seem to make a lot of
sense to put tons of resourcing instant
it's the paper when there's so much work
to do on Pinterest and that there was
much more reliability for getting value
out of the work done in Pinterest right
and then on the data science we talked
about it a little bit and decided I was
just too so most of that work myself and
so we got some agreement that we would
kind of put it keep it in the
maintenance in the maintenance mode and
then essentially I dedicated three four
hours a week to instant paper and
regularly launched new app updates and
fixes servers and do things like that
but large large parts of my focus
shifted to working on Pinterest right
and then and I forget when you told me
you were gonna spin it out but at what
point did you guys decide you're like
you know what we're gonna take this
thing on its own again sure so we had
that conversation late 2016 through 2017
we did a variety of updates starting in
early 2018 so this year yeah I was
thinking a lot about Instapaper long
term trajectory it felt to me that given
the current course it would be out of
path for shutdown just like drawing out
things and I think all things in life
have a certain trajectory that could be
people businesses products yeah but
that's the sad reality of a lot of these
things that get acquired by big
companies they have I mean obviously not
a tremendous amount of users that love
it but like some some amount of users
that love it and then they just like
kind of die quietly as people like you
know get promoted or like buy a house
somewhere and leave and go to another
company yeah it's interesting that
you're like no we want to keep this
alive yeah let's take it yeah I think it
is interesting I think there's a couple
of reasons why we were able to make it
work yeah
just to touch on what you said though a
lot of people were angry about the
pension side position and a lot of
people on Hacker News say people were
listening this podcast were angry about
the acquisition and they had seen I
think a lot of applications that they
loved by the wayside and very similar
things so whether it was mail box with
Dropbox or sunrise with Microsoft or
parse of Facebook I mean there were tons
these things that were these like really
beloved applications I had a cult
following and a lot of users and they
got bought by the big companies they're
no longer kind of in line with the
mission of the original thing they get
integrated or shut down or whatever
turned it to open-source or something
exactly and so I think the reason we
were able to make it work for an instant
paper is instant paper was always run by
a very small team I've always felt that
with our existing user base we could
monetize and cover costs so I think a
lot of these things like some of the
ones I just mentioned they require lots
of Engineers they require lots of
upfront capital and they've been they
basically need to continue to have these
C's pump more money into them you can
continue to grow so they can eventually
become self-sustainable but they're not
self sustainable usually in the forms
and they were acquired in and I think
that in the case of instapaper was very
different it was built by one person ran
by one person for a long time when I
came there were three or four other
engineers as they left I picked up
back-end responsibilities Android
responsibilities website
responsibilities and I basically got to
a part point and I think a lot of people
think Instapaper is like a big thing
with a lot of people I mean basically
from late 2014 through now I've been the
person doing all the backend engineering
all the iPhone engineering Android was
starting 2015 but it's basically just
been me doing all the stuff and so
because of that
I can reduce kind of one of the largest
costs in a company which is the human
cost right and in doing so I was of the
firm belief that we could cover our
server costs with the existing usage and
with like a reasonable conversion rate
on the existing usage I had the benefit
of looking back at a lot of the
historical data on how many subscribers
we had what the growth rates look like
and so on and so forth
and I just felt like this was the type
of product that could continue for the
foreseeable future I knew that it wasn't
ever going to map to a Pinterest
top-line metric or KPI or OKR or
whatever you want to call them and so
basically in early 2018 I had emailed
the CEO Pinterest Ben Silbermann
the subjects and Instapaper and I just
said hey can we chat
I basically had a conversation very
similar to like what we just discussed
which was that it felt like the current
trajectory was for a shutdown I didn't
feel good about that I didn't feel good
about taking away this product from the
many people who use it just because it
didn't map to some top-line metric or
okay our KPI that it had been my
privilege to serve these people and I
wanted to continue to serve them for the
foreseeable future and that I thought
the the two ways we could put into the
paper back on a trajectory where it
could survive for the foreseeable future
is to either treat it like a business
unit within Pinterest which I said my
recommendation was the same
recommendation who may even late 2016
which is that that doesn't make sense or
we can spin it out into an independent
company and so we talked a lot about it
as part of the the discussion we agreed
that it would be like a handshake
understanding that this did not mean I
was leaving Pinterest so the only thing
that would change here is the the
ownership of Instapaper and so now that
Instapaper spun out I run it in a very
similar fashion I was at Pinterest I
dedicate
my nights and one day on a weekend per
month and I fixed all the issues
launching your app updates and so on and
I am trying to build into the paper into
a thing that can sustain himself for the
next 10 years he's been around since
January 2008 celebrated our 10th
birthday in January and I want it to be
a thing that can last for another 10
years it's awesome Ann and you you did
raise a little bit of money now that
it's spun out yeah right so what were
the terms on that what are the
expectations yeah sure
so we raised $80,000 from friends and
family yeah very ragtag like six people
so to kind of give you the average size
I think the largest check was from me
which was 13,000 and then most of the
people had ten some people open a five
the the pitch was interesting because
our express purpose is not to try to
like grow this into a huge thing and
like exit or do anything crazy like our
thing is to make this a long-term type
of business and again like trying to
align like what our customers want which
is they just basically want this service
last forever I think right what the
operators want which is again just to
kind of make it so that this is a
longevity thing and then kind of
aligning what the shareholders the
shareholder pitch they're so essentially
what we said to shareholders was we
structured it as preferred shares and so
we basically said that we're gonna sell
you preferred shares at this price and
your preferred shares will automatically
convert to common shares when we give
you back 125 percent of your investment
so basically what we're saying is we're
going to have a 25% increase on their
investment and we'll automatically
convert them from from preferred to
common shares and then after that mmm
any dividends to investors would be done
across the normal common share equity
split and so the pitch to them was that
you have this 25% return any timeframe
on your investment we said within a year
I think based on current trajectory it
looks like maybe more like 16 months
we'll be able to get there maybe 18
months and then on a yearly basis if we
can afford to do a small dividend will
anta get you 10% monthly investment
return I'm sorry
yearly investment return on your
investment and so there was some risk
upfront here but I think all the people
who were involved there were like a lot
of excavator works people might ant put
in money so it was very friendly you
know I think right and and not like life
breaking amounts of money very small
amounts of money and so there's some
risk but I'm happy to kind of report
that things are going very well that we
do have a lot of people who are
converting to interview for
subscriptions we are now cashflow
positive which is great like couple
thousand dollars a lot of that was
around significantly reducing our server
costs tons of work around that but also
just continued growth in the
subscription offering one thing that I
am trying to piece together is that a
lot of the subscription offerings a lot
of new subscribers are you early
subscribers and so we need to we need to
basically account for that revenue as we
realize it so there's an accounting
practice called deferred revenue so
while we're cashflow positive I don't
know I don't know how we're doing
against our deferred revenue and I think
we want to do it accounting on a
deferred revenue basis meaning that we
would realize the revenue from the
yearly subscriptions in each month that
we actually offer the service so if you
subscribe for a year in August then we
need Naga store 30 divided by 12 and
then the rest throughout the rest of the
year so we're cashflow positive I still
need to figure out a deferred revenue
basis how we're doing as a business
because we need to spread that money
over the whole year ready for server
across any kind of prediction for those
for those people over the year we've
been
this is our third month in business
we're starting to set up books and kind
of do things like that so still early
scrappy days of the new instapaper
it's cool man yeah so you got some
questions - I let's see if there's
anything that are specifically Pinterest
or later all right
so yeah let's do this one that from
djaro
whoo-hoo sounds like you know what types
of product integrations could Pinterest
have done with instapaper yeah so there
were two main ones that we talked about
I think I touched on one which was
taking the aggregate signals from URLs
from Instapaper so how many saves yeah
how many reads they got how many likes
they got we essentially score those four
Instapaper and that powers a feature
called
instapaper daily in spate for daily each
day of the interview for daily gets
rolled up into a weekly email called
Instapaper weekly it's kind of like the
best article saved every day do you name
all the stuff crashing it with a name
the products yeah okay so the daily the
daily was I think I'd named the daily on
the weekly the daily was more a group
effort at the weekly was just kind of an
obvious long we've talked about doing
like a monthly thing - what are you
gonna call it the monthly oh no that's
the idea so pretty social Scott
describing so essentially we we score
those using something called insta rank
which is done by one of the beta works
data scientists and we essentially took
all the URLs and scores from each day
for instant paper and we made them
available to Pinterest with the idea of
having some news based feature within
Pinterest I think one thing that was
interesting is I looked at the
intersection between URLs that we saw in
instead of paper or we had signal on and
it's a paper meaning that there was some
save read like on in a given day and
then compared those to the URLs that
were in Pinterest in each each day and
what I found is that on day on the first
day that we saw those links only 16% of
those links were in Pinterest so we
actually see like a much different set
of humorous on a given day and then over
time I think within seven or eight days
Pinterest gets to like 60 70 80
ten of the links that we're seeing so
there's still like a you know different
set of overlap there but given the
nature of the types of links that
Instapaper has which is very news based
and the types of links and the
experience that we were looking to build
within Pinterest which is like some sort
of news based recommendation system by a
time Pinterest gets those links a lot of
those links are out of the news cycle
yeah and so it's kind of the data the
data is difficult to use and so we built
some experiences around integrating
those signals around having ranking
recommendations for news articles using
those signals but there were these big
gaps where like it took time for these
to make their way out to Pinterest
whereas on instant paper we kind of have
like yeah all these people distributed
on the internet who were saving that
stuff to their accounts and doing it
like very fast as the news breaks and so
that was one reason that product
integration I think didn't work
I think Pinterest is also this
algorithmic recommendation engine that's
heavily based around things that are
kind of more long-term evergreen like
recipes fashion a fashion has cycles but
home decor whereas there's much
different cadence for news and it kind
of changes like the way we do
recommendations that wait so we're a lot
of people just saving like short form
news articles instant paper is that
common I just assumed you would read
those and then anything that's long you
actually save so there's two big use
cases for instigate where there's like
the long-form one which i think is what
you're describing but there's also the
like I want to be able to find this
stuff again right this is more
searchable archive yeah and so people
will save things that they have read and
I do this too I save even like pretty
small things like I've saved things like
campfire recipes so if I go backpacking
or just eating some area just so I can
like kind of get to it really easily and
that offline which in nature you might
be offline so those the two key use
cases I've had a lot where I've read
this like article
about startups or entrepreneurship or
whatever yeah and I wanted to recall it
and get the thing back like pull up the
article again and doing a Google search
sometimes it's like yeah like I can't
remember which which blog it was on or
so and so forth but it's much easier to
do if you have kind of your own personal
search index and if you subscribe plug
for instance or yeah you can search
through all articles you say yeah it
should do a full text search okay cool
so so we do get both and we do get kind
of a different cut versus what Pinterest
gets at least on day zero which is when
when that recommendation is most
important the only other thing that we
kind of looked into was kind of doing
like an offline reader mode for for
Pinterest mmm I think for various
reasons like at the scale of Pinterest
and so on and so forth it's would be
very difficult to do that people save a
lot of things in Pinterest and I think
the expectations are a little bit
different like people expect that all
their instant paper stuff will be
available if we built that expectation
for Pinterest we'd have to store like
ton tons and tons and tons a stuff any
massive videos and just just so many so
much more content because the nature of
the service is actually very different
and so something we discussed in
actually when we were talking about
spitting it out we discussed like maybe
this would be a place of value and I
talked to the head of product about it
and I said like there's so much stuff
that is important for Pinterest right
now and this seems like the type of
thing that seems like a nice idea but
will be infinitely deprioritized behind
like the many other more critical things
we need to do and so I don't really see
that as something that's viable like are
you gonna staff people to do this
project and he was like no and so I said
yeah because it doesn't it doesn't
really make sense to do like all those
like super technical features that's
funny like I think about overcast in
this way like overcast I don't have the
numbers but it seems to be very highly
adopted among nerdy people who want like
crazy granular control over like
notifications per show offline downloads
show but the average person doesn't care
at all yeah and so for Pinterest like
focus on that seems yeah yeah and I
think in sleepers is actually very
similar right I wouldn't describe them
as nerdy I would say they're very
there's continued people who are very
particular about the features that are
in the product they want massive control
over the features in the product they're
very privacy focused and I think Marco
has built a large audience of these
people right so I think what's cool
about Marco is that he has this audience
and so when he launched his products he
launches them directly to this audience
yeah and they typically go and they
download buy subscribe use the products
that he builds and they do it because
mmm Marco is the same type of person who
wants kind of that control those privacy
settings and so on and so forth yeah so
I think it's a great model it's very
cool a lot of people look up to him so
I've got some silly questions in here
all right here we go
Ryan Hoover from producthunt he asks I'm
curious how he and the team a very small
team balance simplicity with new feature
development and product expansion yeah
this is a really good question we've
built basically our product roadmap base
always historically based off of user
requests so people that write in and we
track all those user requests and
essentially we build a model based on
like the most requested features it was
like always oh it's a big thing even
going back to 2014 when I got put into
the general manager role for instant
paper I built this like little this
little table this 3x3 table and the
things that I want to evaluate features
on were did users request it does it
give us a competitive advantage can we
build it into the business model and
then evaluating all the features based
on that and we essentially built a road
map based on what users want thinking
about monetization a little bit and then
also does it give us a competitive
advantage a lot of the features that
we've been requested are very power user
features so people want to like do
highlights they want to create
adaptations they want
to be able to export all their
highlights and annotations to a
third-party service like Evernote or
something like that I'd be amazing
Kindle Amazon exactly I think actually a
lot of people want to take all their
highlights and put them into one place
this notion of like a commonplace book
where like all your learnings are kind
of in one spot and so I know Ezra Klein
who's the editor in chief of Vox uses
instapaper to Evernote and then puts his
Kindle highlights and Evernote using
some service I think it's called
clippings IO and together he kind of has
them all in one Evernote so again it's
like this searchable memory bank
exactly right of all the things that he
reads huh and and so many of the
features are very power user features
some of the other ones are speed reading
text-to-speech again like people use
Instapaper in their car while they're
driving right so they'll put the
playlist on and just go or use the iOS
voice speech-to-text yes speech yeah yes
so your fault yeah so we use the speech
synthesizer there are a couple new iOS
voices that are really great so there's
one called Samantha that's really high
quality and the the one that most of the
most of our users request is called Alex
so Alex is I think it's like a couple
hundred megabytes download but you can
kind of go into the voices and iOS
settings and if you have that downloaded
we can detect it use that by default hmm
so our strategy here for for building
that is to keep the product really
simple for the majority of people it's
already pretty complicated product where
it's like okay you're gonna use this
thing but you're gonna find stuff
elsewhere and then put it in here and
then come back to it it's already like
it's already over like the browser
extension is like well it said too much
yeah yeah you're like gotta install this
here and then it's a challenge and so
our strategy for simplicity with new
future development and it's not a great
strategy is we just hide all the
features we put them kind of in hidden
places and I think our our idea and our
philosophy behind it is the people who
want those features are going to go out
of their way to go find it and we don't
care about moving metrics on specific
features or whatever
what we care about is the overall
product and keeping it simple and so
most of those features like
text-to-speech
and speed reading if you go into the
reader view you press the share button
there in the bottom sheet there and they
may be kind of pushed back based on what
other things that you have there and
what you've configured and if you scroll
on the bottom sheet you can get to the
text-to-speech or the speed reading
features if many people don't know they
exist I think there's a question know it
existed there's a question on here that
says ken Instapaper be voice enabled so
we can yeah we can cross that's a yes
there was one Raymond Dirk asked about
the speed reading so I love rapid
reading mode but would also love a voice
enabled mode where the Google assistant
or Siri reads it speaking out I'd use it
on my Google home to listen to news that
worse yeah so so we do have a voice
enabled mode yeah for for text-to-speech
I think that the home assistant one is
interesting and so I looked into
creating alexis skill for Instapaper
in early 2016 now and I think at the
time it was it was very difficult to do
because you can only pass 500 characters
in a response and then Alexis skill at a
time now Amazon has more recently
launched Amazon Poly which kind of has
some of the Alexa functionality for
developers on AWS and more recently
pocket has done an integration with poly
so they actually send articles to poly
and I can I think what poly returns is
like an mp3 yeah alright and so you can
use poly with your alexis skill i assume
you could do it with sweden I also you
know I think the challenges poly has
some costs associated with it and I
haven't done the math to figure out like
what percentage of users would use this
and what the cost would be but it might
not be feasible for us to do even with
our existing premium model yeah it's
like based on the volume of usage for
each individual user I'm not sure it
would make sense right but it's
something that I'm still looking into
that's particularly just for the Google
home and Alexa
type of environment right how's that
unique consideration I think yeah but I
guess you could always just play it on
your like home speaker yeah you could
always use on your phone and then put it
wherever you want right all right cool
have you tried any of those like
Lyrebird type integrations where it does
a straight up voice emulation so I'm not
familiar with that but we did try a two
different third-party mm-hmm
text-to-speech companies there was one
called ivona which i believe is actually
an amazon company and there was another
one we use that that's slipping me when
embedding those with the mobile
application it blew up the size of the
mobile application like hundreds of
megabytes and so we looked into
downloading the voices asynchronously
and like basically you download the app
and then you download the voices
separately kind of felt like it was a
lot of work even just actually linking
the the text-to-speech library just to
do the functionality blew up the binary
I think two times the actual download so
I was does that materially affect that
number of downloads you get I think only
if you exceed the App Store mobile
download limit so that's changed at the
time it was 50 megabytes I think I
believe now it's 100 or perhaps more but
I think at the time and speaker was 20
or 30 Meg's right now it's 50 Meg's and
linking these text-to-speech libraries
blew it up to like 70 Meg's so at the
time I think it would have dropped app
downloads I think now it's a little bit
easier to do on cellular networks and
other elements are higher but so we're
basically looking at that and then we
have to pay for these things and trading
off against this free stuff that yeah
comes with iOS devices already and we
can use no problem
and it's like fairly good and probably
the quality will improve over time and
so it was a very short-lived type of
experiment yeah we're a massively
changed the app for a small percentage
exactly right okay so Brian Kim asks any
growth hacks that worked well
so we didn't focus too much on growth
acts I think our I think our focus has
always been on delivering good product
it's always been our best growth I and
so is that in the best growth that's
always like basically like when we
shipped features that our users wanted
that our competitors didn't have we were
able to get more users using that now I
think of growth hacks in a more simple
way growth hacks basically is when you
take your product you take a link to it
and you post it somewhere else to try to
take users from another service right
and so if you're Airbnb your growth hack
is posting a craigslist if your genius
your growth hack is making sure that
your Liris pages are at the top of
Google searches for those lyrics there's
a variety of other ones but essentially
they involve go into this other service
and pulling their users that involves
kind of publishing some some content
maybe they're their apartment listings
maybe their lyrics or so on and so forth
the content that we have on the service
is saved from our users and they're from
media publishers or bloggers and we
would never republish that content and
that content is specific to that user
yeah and so a lot of those types of
growth hacks and tactics don't really
work for its the paper there is a
variety of things we could do you can
publish like SEO pages of collections so
we could like have some collections of
articles and try to publish those it's
just never been a big focus area for us
I think probably our biggest growth hack
was removing the paid download right and
and demonstrating that that paid app
download that we removed back in 2014
was a massive barrier to our growth and
today Apple actually goes out and
recommends tap developers that they have
subscription in their apps and they
don't do out downloads I think in 2013
2014 that was less obvious right best
Egyptians were kind of a key piece here
yeah yeah well it's so much more
sure now yeah it was back then all right
Gustav from my seat is curious about
your personal reading habits so how do
you make time for focus
catching up on everything you save and
what are your best productivity hacks
related to this sure so you need to make
that educated time to do this I've
learned and I honestly save more than I
read and read less often than I would
like I found that when I was offline so
for instance when I was in New York City
in the subways back in 2014-2015 there
was no internet service and so there's
nothing else to do so I would read ton
on insta paper that is changing rapidly
I think even in airplanes now most of
them you'll have Wi-Fi I've gone back to
New York and almost every subway station
you have LTE yeah I live here in the bay
I take Bart there's basically service on
the entire BART line and I find that
more and more there's less time I'm
offline where I'm going into the paper
and so I do need dedicated time on the
weekend or nights to actually go through
it and read them there's times like are
we a little bit during lunch especially
if it's work specific articles I think
the best productivity a hack I have
that's instant paper related is on the
mobile application if you press the
ellipsis button in the top right you can
press there's a sort option and you can
sort by shortest article and then I'll
go and I'll just blow through a ton of
short RT is and just do them really
really fast and I'll leave kind of a
bigger meteor ones for later I think
another one that I do is I'll go through
periodically and I'll just delete a
bunch of stuff that I know I'll never
get to especially like there's tons of
Donald Trump articles in there that are
like just just know like like that piece
is about Trump yeah and they're just no
longer relevant because so much has
happened between now between today and 2
or 3 months when I saved it yeah that
it's just no longer interests
hanger relevant and so I'll go through
and I'll delete a bunch of things like
that or like this company raised this
money like I'm like I don't really need
this actually so I think those
combination of things are the the best
productivity hacks I have around it but
making time to actually revisit the
things that you save is very difficult
we've thought about building features to
help with that but it is really hard to
build that type of feature and not
making it massive and massively annoying
for the person using it and make them
feel bad about the same thing as
exercise exactly until you really want
to do it doesn't happen exactly just
guilt exactly yeah do you ever see uh I
don't want to mess of it and these names
Dan Williams in London he made a Chrome
extension that was like send to kindle
but it didn't do anything it was like
javascript:void and it's like you could
just click it it would trigger that
thing and I actually did install it for
awhile because I realized like going
back to my instapaper or pocket or
whatever I was using at the time I could
pretty easily ascertain the stories that
I'm actually gonna read and having more
discipline around that was what allowed
me to get I mean I've never at like
inbox zero on any of this stuff but
closer to it right
also greyscale have you experimented
with that on your phone I haven't I know
it's like a big thing people are doing
grayscale Plus airplane mode yeah yeah
it [ __ ] done yeah because you found just
so lame yeah after that you can actually
read I think the last thing I want to
talk about is yeah all your hiking
ambitions sure what's your what's your
training strategy lately
sure so yeah it's interesting I I'm from
the East Coast I was not into nature I
think you know if you live in New York
there's you kind of get sucked into the
city and the vibe in the Bay Area is
very different and I think the thing
that I've really loved about living here
is the easy access to nature and so I
started just by like exploring and
hiking I didn't like a lot of my like
first hikes here you know just like my
first like ten mile hike things like
that I think as I started pushing the
upper limits on hiking and doing things
like ownio cemetery and doing Half Dome
and doing like these 16 mile hikes
I got into more like camping backpacking
doing much longer hiking mm-hmm
and so I think this year I've done like
ten backpacking trips like all over the
place which has been pretty you did some
big ones you're not just doing like
casual stuff right like you did Whitney
did Shasta another big ones this year
yeah so think those those are the two
big ones so from backpacking it's kind
of been like yeah well some of these
mountains look really awesome right and
so mountain climbing is super dangerous
thing and so when I did Shasta at least
where it was like heavily snow and ice I
went with a company that brings people
up there yeah I'm not trying to like die
on the mountain like you know right yeah
it's dangerous if you don't know what
you're doing exactly so but it's tied in
math Shasta which was great I didn't
Mount Whitney this year which was
extremely hard Mount Whitney is the
highest peak in the lower 48 it's in
California here it's in the Eastern
Sierras near the Nevada border I did
that one basically in a day and went up
and came back it was 13 hours 8,000 feet
of elevation gain
I got a massive headache at the top
which sucked if I do it again I'm
definitely gonna sleep overnight because
II went from Lone Pine right you went
from the east side yeah you start I
slept in the parking lot like right
outside the parking lot yeah and I think
that it's like six thousand seven
hundred feet or seven thousand feet now
and then you go up to 14 five so it's a
pretty big lift for one day yeah there
is a campsite at 10,000 feet I just
didn't get a permit for it
otherwise I'm not a masochist I would
have been a and so I have been doing
these like pretty intense workout
routines for mountain climbing
specifically and it started with just
the Shasta one it was like a 12-week
mountain climbing routine heavily
focused on endurance so a lot of cardio
a lot of like long cardio sessions
yesterday I did an hour on the
Stairmaster with 20 pounds in my
backpack and just just kind of doing
things like that and I think what I've
realized is like you you do hit these
walls but the more you can kind of like
you know you like where you feel like
you want to give up and then where you
can like
through them and get used to like
hitting the wall breaking through it
breaking through it and doing that in
the gym versus on the mountain is is
kind of a good strategy and so I have I
have some more ambitions like I don't
think I'm ever going to like want to do
Everest right like this like that's a
little like real climbing like too
extreme he's climbing I would I would be
interested in that I just I want to
balance like having a good time outside
with being safe oh you know yeah but
there's the whole categories like type 2
fun and yeah I agree with you I I fall
into the camp of enjoying the suffering
not the dangerous part yes exactly and I
think with Everest like if you need to
put oxygen on in order to get up it's
like you know maybe just you know I know
people do it but it just seemed I know
people do it without oxygen and those
people are awesome yeah but it just
seems to me like maybe a step beyond
what what my ambitions are there but I
would like to do like Mount Rainier
there's a couple in South America that
I'm kind of interested in doing at least
like on here and it's kind of been like
a whole new thing for me
this this whole area and and so
something I've really enjoyed living out
here in California and exploring cool
man well if someone wants to get in
touch with you or reach out to you on
the Internet's what should they do
sure Twitter is probably the best place
my Twitter handles bth Donoghue I
usually give out my email too but it's a
lot of people about it so if if you
reach out to me on Twitter I will give
you my email address and we can chat but
I think that's probably will start with
Twitter : alright thanks for making time
yep
thank you
you